primer ministro y reino unido boris
johnson el presidente de ucrania global min
seles quien es impregnano porsche
oi sorpresa en la capital ucraniana que
los británicos si ad es desplazado desde
premio anuncio detective johnson ha
listo o palabra mudù le dice a rusia de
que estan haciendo en ucrania
crímenes de guerra por ataque
enfrentamientos deliberados a la población
pues gana una visita
significativo que el segundo de madrid
quién inició un conflicto y quién
es necesario cuando bruselas está sola
Walking Ucrania sea el proceso
de adhesión y la unión europea de
es la Comisión Europea o
pronunciado a favor de la concesión
del pais estatuas candidatas a ingreso
y la europea cara a una club
reunión importante que si tomará la
cable la semana que hay en eso
27 y son llamados a pronunciar e
precisamente por encima del té tomado bien
noticias portanto para se lensky quien sabe
de lo que tu hashana el camino de
cráneo para ser la victoria en el Europeo
cura pero si en un momento dificil
para pais extranjero puede ser el ejercito
nuestro trabajo sosteniendo diferentes fas y en
particular en la zona de donbass ita
binachi a far kim no se encuentran y
acoplamientos de momento y motores o comprobar
que el frente encuentro a es al
al norte esta importante desde ukrania
nas y reactivado